[Music]
special edition of the dish this morning
Alan Stillman he's been revolutionizing
how we eat and meet for more than five
decades his singles bar would grow into
a worldwide restaurant chain and the
steak houses he found it are iconic I
cut up with Stillman a few weeks ago
here in New York at Smith and Wollensky
iconic Midtown Chop House it's all about
the steak and the sizzle all of that
describes founder Alan Stillman but it's
his unique philosophy on restaurant life
that takes the cake
fake it until you make it what made you
think you had the skill set to do this
lack of knowledge I had no understanding
that I couldn't do it he opened his
first bar and restaurant in 1965 with a
$5,000 loan from his mother is it fair
to say you got into the business because
you wanted to meet women absolutely fair
not only fair but accurate and true and
it worked but you insisted on good food
you insisted on an atmosphere excuse me
I insisted on good french fries and
hamburgers sure we just discovered it as
we went along the bar would become a hot
spot for unmarried men and women on New
York's Upper East Side it was a magical
clientele that provided the perfect
combination I think that you have been
dubbed the man who invented the singles
bar no they only call me the man that
invented the single spa I happened to
open up a restaurant that turned into a
single spa at the time it was an awful
lot of luck involved the first piece of
luck was calling a TGI Fridays Stillman
would go on to open around 12:00 TGI
Fridays before selling there are now 870
restaurants around
world is it a kick to see that your
singles bar is now like a
family-friendly restaurant neither way I
do get a kick of getting out of a plane
in Istanbul and having a TGI Fridays in
my face 50 years later that I get a kick
out of but in 1974 Stillman decided it
was time to sell and took off for Europe
six years later he opened another iconic
landmark although Smith & Wollensky was
the restaurant that's stumbled out of
the gate that first review in the New
York Times for Smith Lewinsky here yes
that almost put us out of business in
1978 how did you recover
we recovered by taking out two full-page
ads in the New York Times and they said
with a matchbook cover at last a match
for the palm and chrysella and the
following week we started doing business
in double and more than double every day
Stillman has opened and sold seven Smith
& Wollensky from Chicago to London
always maintaining ownership of the
flagship here in New York there really
is no Smith and no Lewinsky is there no
Smith so where did the name come from
sitting around here a little bit smash
maybe a little bit stoned two three
weeks before opening and absolutely Joe
name whatsoever and a lot of money
invested and we find he said at 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning get a phone book
and we took the New York City phone book
and we put it on the table and we
flipped the first page and up came Smith
and we said no no you can't call them
placements that's not possible so we
flipped it again and it came up with
linski and somebody said no you can't
call the place with Winsky I got up the
next morning I said hey we said we're
going to do it let's use both names will
you Smith and Wollensky and it went from
there
from father to son Michael Stillman
oversees the family's 11 quality branded
restaurants and what can feel like a
classic mom-and-pop shop the Stillman's
employees have been around for decades
so how long lives the two of you
collectively worked here at Smitha
Wilensky I need a calculator 45 Wow
45 in 37 37 that's a lot of years yes it
is Danny Kasane started carrying boxes
in 1981 today he's director of
purchasing overseeing all the meat for
the restaurant manager Sam Pak started
bartending at TGI Fridays in 1973 and
has been with Stillman ever since
there's a culture of loyalty and respect
that came from Allen and no matter what
has changed he is still the same well
considering it is your birthday I'd like
to raise a glass I thank you very much
to business well done and well earned
and I don't know when your birthday is
but you to a 39 only once I'll be 40
coming up next year what a character
I'm telling you know it runs in the
family I his son quality meets quality
eats the whole shebang he did not even
think about the restaurant business yeah
until mid 20s and when you think about
what he's done and the legacy now that
he has it Sammy I tell you when you see
employees or been with a company that
long it tells you everything you want to
know about all will run